[Narrator:] Bill Macalilly, 52 years old,
former naval officer once athletically inclined.
Formerly a vigorous and active man.
Today Bill finds himself winded after half a block's walk,
so short of breath he must stop to rest before continuing the rest of the way.
By the time he reaches his car,
he is so out of breath that he needs a whiff of oxygen
to bring him back to normal.
Frank Ussery, former construction worker,
spent his spare time hunting and fishing.
Today the act of shaving, a routine and effortless task to most men,
taxes him so that he has to stop frequently to catch his breath,
even though he sits and leans on the sink to conserve his energy.
[Music]
Harry Krause, formerly a farmer,
has to go through this process four times each day
to clear his lungs of accumulated fluids
so he can lead a very limited existence comfortably.
These men share in common with an estimated 13 million Americans
a disabling disease that can make every breath of air they draw a major effort.
They have emphysema.
[Music]
[Narrator:] When emphysema strikes, the act of breathing,
an involuntary function to healthy people, becomes hard work,
sometimes demanding most of the strength the body can muster,
leaving its victims gasping for air.
Emphysema victims often find themselves drowning in a sea of air,
unable to obtain the life-supporting oxygen their systems require.
To Bill Maccalilly and his family,
this is an ever-present threat.
[Bill Sr.'s wife:] Well, we'd been to the grocery store and I went out to the car,
it was about to rain and I picked him up at the door,
and we had two fairly heavy bags of groceries,
which he lifted into the car and...
I guess that was it,
it just took his breath completely,
and I had forgotten to put the little ball of oxygen we normally carry
into the car we drove out here,
and I thought I might have to run him
by the hospital before we got here.
But he got his breath all right,
and we made it,
but that was one of the worst times I've seen him have lately.
[Bill:] Mm hmm.
[Bill Sr.'s wife:] Maybe it was the humidity.
You never really know.
[Bill:] It musta been the air probably.
It's real frightening not to be able to get your breath.
Uhh I have a tank, a tank at home,
I have a tank out here with a face mask and regulator.
I have a ball of oxygen that I take in the car with me,
so that wherever I go I have access to the oxygen.
And I don't need it every day,
but the fact that it's there gives me a self-assurance,
gives me confidence that if something should happen,
I have the oxygen available.
And that does as much for me possibly as the oxygen itself.
[Bill Sr.'s wife:] And of course I've learned to live with,
we have learned to live with this,
but at first, I was scared to death frankly all the time uhhm.
When Mack would leave the house,
I would be like this until he got back because I was just sure
he was going to die before he would get back.
In fact I worried myself into a nice little ulcer
during that period but ummm, then gradually we learned
what emphysema was and how it affected a person
and what we had to do to learn to live with it.
So, I'd say we've improved considerably in that direction, too.
[Bill:] I look big and strong and healthy,
but I can't take physical exertion, so people look at me rather
funny when I'm walking along and she's carrying the bag,
or when we come up to the door and she lets me out,
and then she walks back, uhh.
Makes, makes it kind of embarrassing
and I attempt to cover that in many ways by stopping and resting,
or stopping and looking at something,
and just not seeing her doing these things.
A lot of the times I do that. Bill has taken over a lot of this,
she has taken over a lot of it.
I don't do anything very much anymore
that requires physical exertion.
That's probably one of the things that bothers me most.
I could do a lot of these things at one time,
and now I can't and it's a rather frustrating experience.
It's sometimes disillusioning to think, well sure I can do this.
Then I find that I can't, I have to quit.
And this is one of the substitutes that I've found.
I make bedspreads and tablecloths, placemats, uh, afghans.
There are a lot of things can be done that would take away energy
that I expended in athletic contests,
or events prior to this that I now have to do something
that doesn't take that much physical exertion.
The absence of oxygen makes me tire very easily,
and many times I come home from school, put on my pajamas,
have dinner, go right to bed because that's the only energy that I have.
And by doing that I can teach.
Whereas if I tried to do a lot of other things,
then I couldn't, I'd just be completely out,
completely without energy.
[Bill Sr.'s wife:] He's, he's learned to conserve himself
for the jobs that he wants to do and wants,
you know, enjoys doing and can do.
He spends many weekends in bed too,
but that's fine that,
by doing that, he's able to go to school and do his work, so...
[Narrator:] What does Bill suspect is the cause of his disease?
[Bill:] Possibly smoking and the fact that I, uhh,
well we don't know for sure.
I had pneumonia twice and I smoked heavily,
so they don't know whether the smoking caused it
or whether the pneumonia caused me to have emphysema.
But the theory is the smoking, heavy smoking caused it.
[Narrator:] Despite his father's condition and suspicion, Bill junior smokes.
[Bill Jr.:] I thought about quitting a couple times,
but uh, I never have gotten around to it,
and uh, I don't smoke in front of him often.
Sometimes when we play cards and we're together for long periods of time,
I'll have one in front of him,
but uh, I don't know sometimes,
when I've done something active
like I play football and bowl, things like that.
And when I get short of breath,
it makes me wonder sometimes, you know,
am I headed for something like that?
And at those times particularly I think about quitting,
but uhh...in fact I did quit for about a month.
But I couldn't lose the desire.
[Interviewer:] How much do ya smoke?
[Bill Jr.:] Ohh anywhere from a half a pack to a pack a day.
I don't smoke heavily yet, and nowhere near as heavily
as he used to smoke.
[Bill Sr.'s wife:] I predict that he'll have it though.
I really think he will; he has some of the same symptoms already
that his father has.
Sniffly nose and um, they both get sneezing spells, I'll call them,
and they'll sneeze 15 or 20 times,
and then they'll end up with a cold.
And Bill does that,
so he's very much like his father in a number of ways as you can see.
I really think he's uh, a good suspect.
[Interviewer:] Prospect.
[Bill Sr.'s wife:] Prospect then.
[Bill:] I wish he would quit,
the same way probably that my father wished that I would quit.
Uh I think I have more visible evidence, though,
of what it can do to ya than uh, I had from my father.
So I wish he would quit because I think it would be to his advantage,
not only from a health standpoint,
but from a monetary standpoint, because it's expensive to smoke,
as well as being a health hazard.
[Narrator:] Although there is no known cure for emphysema,
certain infrequent cases may be given some relief through surgery.
Harry Krause is a case in point.
He knew the operation was very risky,
but felt he had nothing to lose.
[Harry:] I was no good to myself or anybody else.
I couldn't take a bath myself or anything else and uh,
I required help to do everything.
And uh, uh it was a living death if you want to put it like that.
[Narrator:] According to Dr. Thomas D. Bartley,
the surgeon who performed the operation,
Harry Krause's specific condition warranted the surgery.
[Dr. Bartley:] A similar situation is depicted here in this whole lung section,
prepared at the research center in Jacksonville's Baptist Memorial Hospital.
The upper part of this lung has been destroyed by emphysema.
The lower parts...
uh, have disease in them as shown in these lightened areas here.
However, there is enough preservation of the normal architecture
so that one could guess that removal of this part,
which is overinflated and compressing, or squashing,
the more normal areas, might result in improved function within this lung.
This of course occurred in Mr. Krause's situation,
and though he was totally disabled prior to his operation,
he has been able to return to a relatively normal level of activity.
[Narrator:] Although surgery did improve Harry's condition,
emphysema still forces him to lead a very limited life.
[Harry:] I turned the entire business setup over to her,
and, however, I am able to help in an advisory capacity,
I can do no work at all, I can't lift anything.
Trying to agitates it,
and then you get clear down to where
you can't even take care of yourself,
and it takes you a long time to build back up
and get the uh stamina you would have if you didn't try.
Walking too fast, too far tires you out.
Any carrying, even to the extent of five pounds in your hands
tires you out right now because in my condition right now it overloads me.
I can carry the weight that I've got if I'm very, very careful.
But if I add anything to it,
like a heavy overcoat or a big pair of boots or something like that,
it wears you out.
[Harry's wife:] Oh, you have to do, do a lot of extra work.
Things that he can't do and all the taking care of him when he is down.
[Narrator:] To live with emphysema,
the Krauses have had to make many adjustments.
[Harry's wife:] You just don't go anymore, or do things
that you used to do for pleasure, you know.
It's stay home practically all the time.
[Harry:] You don't have any social life.
All the friends that you had, you used to go out with in the evening and things like that,
they drift away knowing the condition and everything.
You have friends that drop in on you,
and your close relations stick by you,
but uh, that's the extent of your social life.
You lose all contact
because you just can't go in public places with anything like this.
The doctors advise against it
because colds are transmitted and if I get one, I'm in trouble.
[Narrator:] For a man who formerly led an active life,
slowing down to almost a standstill has its obvious problems.
[Harry:] Yes I was active all my life.
In fact, we built this place here ourselves and uh,
all the hard work that's in it, we put in it,
and uh we've been that way all of our lives.
We worked hard and had to work, you might say, for what we got.
That's the hardest thing for somebody that's got a lot of ambition,
to keep from doing, is overdoing with something like this,
because if you overdo it,
you set yourself back to where you can't even get around.
You just gotta quit everything and go in complete rest.
[Narrator:] In his battle to breathe,
Harry must go through an exhausting effort
to clear the fluid from his respiratory system four times each day.
[Harry:] We take the machine for approximately a half an hour
and that has medicine in it and we fill our lungs with that machine,
and then after that we get down on the floor
and my wife pushes on my one side and then the other side,
and then my back.
[Interviewer:] So what was the cause of  emphysema?
[Harry:] Well, I believe the cause, I'm sure the cause was cigarettes.
[Interviewer:] How much did you smoke?
[Harry:] Well, at one time I smoked about four packs a day,
and towards the last it was two regular.
I guess that's partly my trouble,
if I hadn't smoked at that time probably,
it wouldn't have been as bad on me.
But you just don't do those things,
of course in those days you didn't know what cigarettes was gonna do to you in later life,
but uh now they're beginning to find out.
[Narrator:] For Frank Ussery,
almost totally incapacitated by emphysema for the past four years,
the routine task of shaving is a major physical effort.
[Frank:] Well, I just get out of breath soon as I'm shaving...
and uh, I don't have the strength to sit down,
to stand up to shave, I give out,
my legs give out on me.
And I sit on that stool,
but it's not so comfortable, guess it's too high or something.
And of course if I take my arms
and lay 'em on the sink or something and use one hand at a time,
it's not quite so bad,
but it takes strength, just moving my arms around.
It takes strength and...
I don't have too much of it,
I guess, I get tired.
I...while I'm shaving I take time once in a while
and rest for a few seconds, ten, 15, 20 seconds, 30 seconds,
and I start again,
and I get by with it that way.
Exertion takes all my strength away from me.
[Interviewer:] What, for instance, what kind of exertion?
[Frank:] Well walking, walking,
mostly just walking, 'cause that's about all I do.
I wouldn't have any energy enough
to do any kind of work.
Uh I don't even write any letters anymore.
Dressing tires me, stooping over,
to put on my socks and my shoes.
Standing up, putting on my pants and bending down,
putting my shirt on.
Well uh if I do it, if I do it slowly,
I can gradually go ahead, probably take me three or four five minutes
to get my pants and my shirt on
and then I won't be out of breath when I get it on.
But then when I walk from uh, the bedroom into the kitchen uh,
I couldn't begin to start drinking coffee right then
because my breath is so short.
I just haven't got the breath
and that, that's the way, it tires me to eat even,
particularly eating fast, to try to chew fast.
It actually tires me to talk too long.
Well, I worry most that I can't get out and do
the things I like to do.
Just cooped up in the house all the time.
I can't even drive a car anymore.
Even with power steering,
I don't have the strength.
Even jostling up and down in the car,
it tires me out.
[Frank's wife:] We've always enjoyed going on trips so much
and we all used to love to visit our neighbors,
and now that's impossible.
We don't even get to go to church together.
I have to go to the church service in the morning,
and then come home and listen to the 11 o'clock service with Frank.
Just seeing him this way
is just the most tragic thing to me.
But uh, and then I used to depend on him so much to do things for me,
and now he can't even dry dishes.
And uh, I think that's been a lot in our lives.
It's just the idea he just cannot do things for himself,
or for me, either one, or for anybody else.
And he's always been so active and fished and hunted
and everything like that but now he just...
He loves to read and look at the TV,
but that's about the only thing, recreation he gets.
[Frank:] If I should want to go get in the car
and walk to the car,
if I walk real slow, I do a whole lot better.
If I try walk fast to the car,
by the time I get out there
I'd be so completely out of breath I can hardly catch my breath.
[Narrator:] Frank's condition causes his wife a great deal of apprehension.
[Frank's wife:] And then it's always so frightening to me at night
when I'm here all by myself with him
and I'm always so afraid he's going to get sick during the night.
But so far he's done pretty well about that.
But uh, I think that's enough,
and it's been worrying me, it's just the idea that
he might need me during the night and I wouldn't know it.
[Narrator:] Frank, too, cites cigarettes as the probable cause of his emphysema.
[Frank:] I was smoking cigarettes,
and I guess like 90 percent I might say, these cigarettes,
I guess caused me to be short breath, but I wouldn't quit smoking.
Probably like an average man would, I don't know.
[Nurse:] Blow out your breath, keep it out.
[Narrator:] There is still a great deal to be learned about emphysema.
At the University of Florida Medical Center and other hospitals throughout the country,
intensive research is underway
to develop a cure for this disease,
whose victims are increasing in alarming proportions.
[Doctor:] Faster.
[Narrator:] Social security disability payments to emphysema patients
rank second only to those made to people disabled by heart disease.
Under laboratory conditions,
the effect of emphysema on work capacity can be carefully measured.
[Doctor:] We're following Mr. Ussery's heart rate and breathing rate
as he recovers from an exercise load.
His ability to exercise against a known load
is approximately half a normal person's ability.
His emphysema has caused this and is shown by a rapid breathing rate
even three to five minutes after he stopped pedaling.
[Doctor:] ...Emphysema such as Mr. Ussery has is a disease of the lungs
caused by bronchitis, a narrowing of the small airways.
And also a destruction of the lung tissue itself.
The bronchitis, or the obstruction part, causes the lungs to overinflate.
They balloon up so that a patient is forced to breathe
on top of them, so to speak.
If we look here, we can see how a normal person breathes quietly
and then when he takes in a deep breath,
he can bring in up to three liters or over three quarts of air,
and blow out rapidly almost five.
But a person with emphysema is starting at a high point in his lung volume
and he can only take in one or two quarts.
And worst of all, he can blow out only slowly two or three quarts of air.
Now the diffusion, the way the tissue of the lungs take up oxygen
and put it into the bloodstream
that courses through the lungs from the air that a person breathes,
is important and a normal person's value might be 20.
A patient such as Mr. Ussery has destroyed much of his lung tissue
and can take up only half as much as a normal person can.
When a person can't breathe deeply and can't exhale rapidly,
he becomes desperately short of breath.
He can't work,
he is in trouble at home just getting around the house.
His ability to support his family is ruined.
We can't cure emphysema; we can help patients that have it.
They should not give up hope.
We can get them to quit smoking
and guarantee a certain return in their ability to work.
We can also use medicine such as adrenaline
for them to breathe and dilate those small bronchial tubes.
We give them exercises for posture
and to help them bring up the secretions out of their lungs.
[Narrator:] Many health authorities still refer to emphysema's cause as unknown.
Increasingly however,
researchers are placing the lion's share
of the blame on a single source.
[Doctor:] The important way to get rid of emphysema is not treatment,
it's to teach children that the long-term effect of cigarette smoking
is very dangerous to their health.
[Sound of man using breathing machine, coughing, and wife pounding on his back.]
[Narrator:] Mark Twain once observed that each person is born with one possession which outvalues all his others.
His last breath.
Emphysema victims have gone Mark Twain one better.
In their day-in day-out battle to keep their lungs working,
they have come to cherish not just their last breath
but their every breath.
[Man coughs, woman pounds on his back, breathing machine whirs.]
[Music]